ils sont de plus en plus nombreux en
forêt du gâvre à se battre contre le
projet de l'office national des forêts
même si loana a concédé pour rendre ces
réalisations possibles
une charte de bonne conduite qui
interdirait les temps à tout acte de
chasse mais autoriserait les veneurs à
le traverser
oui prendre un cerf un combat qui vit
d'abord l'ouverture d'une concertation
qui depuis le début de l' affaire n'a
jamais eu lieu entre les différentes
parties pas de concertation a priori
avec les acteurs que ce soit la mairie
du gave
que ce soit les habitants les habitants
du coin les habitants un peu plus âge
les associations lohan ait fait des
conventions par exemple avec la ligue
pour la protection des oiseaux ils ont
jamais été consultés une concertation
donc pour trouver une alternative car
les riverains de l'étang n'ont pas
l'intention de subir les nuisances
occasionnées par les chasseurs à courre
et leurs suiveurs à 500 mètres de chez
eux
là où les serres finissent leur course
lors de chasse qui dure six mois par an
ici l'on est conscient de la nécessité
d'un point d'eau en ce dieu précis mais
l'objectif est d'arriver à un compromis
un compromis qui serait un étang
écologique servent pour la faune pour la
flore qui sera positif pour la forêt
mais à but pédagogiques c'est-à-dire où
les monde puisse venir observer la
nature etc et surtout un étang qui soit
interdit à tout acte de chasse ça il
faut que ce soit clair
les travaux de creusement aurait dû
commencer en octobre dernier espoir des
habitants de la magdeleine à présent
trouver une solution rapide
[Musique]